[Music]
joysticks still not aware Brad but it is
two kills three for Shepard and the
Empire Strikes Back
they will take the role emajor and
disbelief how quickly it comes back
where it all began for Empire ladies and
gentlemen your winners of the Raleigh
major 2019 team
[Applause]
hey guys Dimitri from the score eSports
in Raleigh North Carolina where we just
witnessed an amazing Rainbow six siege
major wrong rotation has a shot to Cory
oh my god that reaction now if you
missed out on any of the action or just
want to relive the rainbow six glory
that was we got you covered with the
best big brain utility plays the most
jaw-dropping clutches and the sickest
kills beautiful therefore is wrath of
the devil nitro and now he's just hiding
inside of the gold fox her to the core
with the pre fire laughter the bars are
you kidding me now before we delve into
this weekend's action remember that
Rainbow six eSports doesn't end with the
Raleigh major there'll be plenty of US
Nationals action taking place in the
coming months to keep up with it all be
sure to check out the links in the
description below now let's get on with
the best place from the Raleigh major
starting with these insane plushies
sniff you alone now and a1 b3 in the
depths of kitchen as the plant is going
down that smoke won't come anywhere
close to stopping a bush shuttle will
pull off it's the nice shot on a slash
they're not sure how he's alive but
rotating to the hallway being constantly
spotted on the road team EP takes out a
cliff try to go for the 1 b 3 team
secret to continue to take the lead on
coastline in nearly stylistic fashion bc
a knife to work together as a tandem
flights up bc hyper covering from the
rafters possible down them now needs to
turn the corner and quickly to kill ty
for trying to sell free vive and bc
heading over into the rafters piper back
on his feet all it takes is one shot
though beautiful push there from Pasha
Pasha load in the 1 b2 for stay alive in
the back of the young superstar in just
the one or two shots there's your Shingo
with the first fine to get some hobbies
two more to go in time is also running
low there is the second pick up for him
he's gonna try to run downstairs and
employ the flash player eventually
essentially trying to just dodge the
fight as he knows you have to go for the
plant and it works out perfectly or
Shingo should
easy clicks in there it is right in
front of them the 1v3 but snoring go up
to Matt point first as they lead at six
to five once again Hicks the lone man
for Giants comes on a knoll when he
takes down shockwave he's only got one
more body and he'll rotate as kama is
blind and codes for the plant in the
corner that can fix not trying to play
off of the diffuser pasta folds up oh it
didn't want a coach from him it's
Kalamata to seal the deal not Pasha
amidst the scramble it's okay we're in
two versus one look at the time so
little left on that diffuser wtg coming
down spiral now and it's gonna be a
flight from the smoke will he see his
opponent yes pips with the kill on wtg
but is there time it looks like there
will be the Giants keep themselves in
this and we go to 6 to 7 seconds will
determine the fate here is Sheppard
shooting up the black I cam he's gonna
have to plant
he's very exposed a MAV will come on up
knowing that he's at a time map you need
to find him hurry man you got a second
left there you go pull up the depot your
fall is so far phase for nothing
absolutely hard to watch now Scyther has
to pick up the mantle here less than
half the time remaining in order to get
onto the fuser hear me P is gonna be
spotted on the outside cypher takes the
dueling wins it now is the hard part now
he's got to deal with the player
upstairs and this is not going to be an
easy factor all he does not have the
nitrosyl to confirm the easy kill Oh
what is this
there's roll away that Leon's gonna be
able to read into this maybe yeah though
he's noticed that the nade goes in it's
gonna improv it shook it up
two layer three billion IQ from the
safer to punch out the round continues
that Gert get aggressive they have the
pinch they need but Dan can't land the
shots quickly rotates in switch it over
the pistol still can't final cut second
fit down BP takes one pigs back within a
second baby with a triple kill to keep
them alive that's how you fly it out of
a boss sprang into the wind
Shepherd goats were rushed eats a lot of
damage but doesn't lose the fight just
yet
thank you alive but he only gets one can
he get the second he's so close he runs
back to the fuser flow on time the last
is a perfect post plant positioning and
G to win another round who from Empire
can stop the momentum what site sir he
pops up he's completely detected and
gogo is removed from action hard
creature is down Scyther right now all
what a c4 that is and a double kill once
again sight they're so good
Shepherd will get his own downing you
know and it's all thank you it's like
third for sight there this is outlandish
come on man four kills now great
clutches go hand in hand with great
kills which is why our next section
shows off the flashiest executions to
take place at the Raleigh major
beautiful there from reroutes the double
nitro and now he's just hiding inside of
the gold Fox herd in the corner with the
prey fire after the bars are you kidding
me they'll hear the c70 is Hyper's
falling off you'll have to go for the
kill he doesn't have a lot of time he
knows this and unless there's some
miracle in the very final second
Piper he pulls it out with a second to
go right as the clock strikes zero and
that'll be match point now for dark zero
spawn here from Dan this is a pretty
rudimentary spot supposed to be say
below anything it's gonna be murk to
fall
they didn't even drone the hallway Oh
[Applause]
Joe good night my friend smoke pretty
gonna go in it does implode should delay
the plan a little bit musii takes out a
teammate but he also finds young as well
canadian striking back with two though
let's look for a planet believe they
hear that so they're gonna look to be
opportunity here we go a little bit man
through docks up the planter it's just
one player left alive here now for men
IP to keep their chances alive otherwise
it's eg taking this matchup no time left
for it to happen however Agee shut it
down on the timer and with that take
control of the series two to nothing
maybe and now rotating over through
cigar long rotation here has a shot the
quarry oh my god that reaction one
bullet is all he needs
that was absolutely insane just flick
the one top off I'm just trying to make
sure there's nothing too crazy up an
aggressive being thrown out here by TSM
for the most part they've been avoiding
that on this map you're not able to do
it as much as you can on cafe au surgeon
be glancing into the overtime now Hicks
rushing through the gas Paul bas for the
great cover
Holly needs to do is hit the second one
now the hipfire
no idea what is inside of the closet Oh
Cory on the 180 and then Cheyenne's will
take their first lead of the day nearly
an adjustment for mark he's not gonna
get fully eliminated Cyril finished the
job but I'm so alone I think they
interrupt this place so close to
stopping at each I nee is the hole to do
it
my goodness biologic just barely getting
the kill off in time with his pistol
before the rap comes in from the IQ and
down inside of kegs in the safe corner
plant will be completed here is neither
member of face close enough for now now
with the wall banking left the walk soft
and they played the retake onto the site
faze clan now one round away from the
main stage this is not good he knows
he's got somebody inside of garage yes
he might be able to capitalize on it all
we get sit down and are we about to see
it
Nath's ladies and gentlemen
interrogation fair we'll get them
goodbye / all alone in the garage final
logic and not very much help it's a
quick shot it's a team kill shaved to
win it out TSM on map match everything
point oh that's just the capsule coming
in this time for years nice shot
toxicity continues rise workshop is so
nice on peak barely managed to catch
cars ekor there but car sucka gets the
kill himself instead he turns it back
around Oh mark as well to find him and
take him down
so he'll be gone in a matter
oh the head off slash is built away with
viola peon kids what a shot
and what a static target playing on this
defensive favorite playing so well Oh
Corey with the long shot there
Bosco just not not training that out
favorably flexib through the wall hoping
for a lucky wallbang he's got 30 seconds
to hold on while nora ringo will come
from the same angle the sofia will walk
and distract it perfectly oh ma the
goodness the gracious and the shots as
he lands all of them and that's three
kills and two very quickly with the
beautiful flick and then the other as
well for good measure doesn't even need
a stim pistol it's a little too late for
feral Road will get by unscathed the
lens down now and rogue are managing to
make this work a c4 gets lost out may be
doing so much work shut gun out he knows
he's got one more innocence to fight in
the back of shuttle will find the front
instead of 4k from meat-beef that's how
you start a map and coastline round
number one oh he might be able to get
that initial fried areas gonna get drone
doubt they'd recognize it out contact
rotates through is he gonna get it go
big sup px way again great the lathes
for the name of the game so far from eg
on this site Obama making a push through
the two now three kills going into his
favor absolutely ripping through the
defenses right now with all of a sudden
everything is on Young and Aces will
take him out what a recovery from the
child fill the time on a plan to execute
but it's certainly softest things up now
and softens back go
after with a run out on the two and a
Bissell finish your foursome out of
position he's gonna waste so so much
time and even me goes out a kill it
doesn't matter it because there you go
immediately if trade comes in from geo
right after NBK is dealt with all the
cons are the one to strike it but Giulio
is the one that falls in the trio into a
2v2 the 17 seconds left here we need to
see the push from an IP but they just
don't have room to do it geo shuts out
kamikaze on an easy pick and now we're
down to only one lose you also get shut
up by geo as Evil Geniuses shut it down
on the final round of the map but then
getting that one pick that was just
witnessed Empire is still playing
offsite looking to deny the push Shepard
gets eliminated by ion that's huge
big loss for Chris Carr Zeca gets his
third kill and he's going for a forfeit
he kicks it incredible but he shut down
by yuna utility hogs both sides of the
coin
but mvk gonna be playing that along
angle as he's gonna click the head off a
kamikaze shoulders and soon enough
ninjas pajama starts to fall apart Rask
1 still alive is going to punish the
Giants or that clear of the top ward
he's still up there another one goes
down to Ross get that free a triple kill
from the top of yellow CCTV but then
they're shifting over to office it's a
yeah it's messy but Rask is in sight how
does he do it and he's got two for
himself looking for a third and he gets
it the pistol out for ask and he's
finally on the floor but what does that
matter the rest of four is adding to the
tally and it's just a fizz all of a
sudden and it's a post plant with three
people still alive from fours this could
be a tricky spot from the Giants and
they're gonna have to take chances all
but wtg is there along with karma and
it's all Cole
but wtg shuts the door nobody's stopping
them at all fours are up for oh what a
performance so far on border very low on
HP from his previous engagement with
bonkers when thrown to counteract the
upside-down rappel and there he goes
again
[ __ ] press right up against the
window sell me P with another one as I
said she try to charge through bar but
the being repelled the gates the smoke
not enough covered another one for
bonkers Oh baby that's feral instead
that what about a nasty shoppin foggers
hopefully reigniting the potential for
MIT article Oh team secret are doing
laying throwing corners as they know
they cannot stand and fight from any
engagements there goes one in Fockers to
the wall why's them both up team seeker
will take map number one off the space
station then they push in through have
an office the rest of it and they go for
a place to cover with those two players
that I do mentioned earlier and from
there with that crossfire
they have full control of being home and
there's very little many teams have been
able to do to deny the plant then
following that control also waited
through there's a very aggressive play
as well on damn what is this oh what a
nice shot by elem 20 seconds remain
though for the attackers once again
Empire is gonna be stretched the bar
limit of their attack if they do play
into open area here trying to work
towards that this is where the freedom
allows them to play before but the
problem is car CEQA will just swing
around on the 180 quickly pick up the
second hill and close out the round for
Empire and team secret might be trying
to apply that right now it does have
some pressure Moreau upstairs with a
quick shot from Barker's he doesn't even
need the help he doesn't need any of it
push it to mappoint side the rotating up
mean now
these track stickers have been taken
care of feral again the trip will kill
it's all lit up the cipher because he
shows up on the graves of his friends
plant now going down they all know sigh
those inside of aquarium he's not using
to rotate off barrel with a pencil don't
play now coming in for Empire recognize
and help that's maestro who limbs is
sitting behind the half wall here Jeff
that was joystick picks up two maybe in
Parkers ball it's all - lets - he
crosses sandwich joystick with a shake
in a moon if it will fall this gonna be
immediate trade as soon all the limbs as
well as punkers but Leon's there to
assist is all of a sudden we're equal
than man counts either now rotates
upstairs a quick shot from Leon to put
cycler in the dirts and they're trying
to find a will in a way to get through
this because that could try to equalize
and Leon throw that concussion with the
triple you never say that buddy finds
away there we go but no they go right in
the Dan it's even it's simpler now but
Leon also makes a run down the hallway
turn on the Dan we're going crazy early
on finds his own personal second and
third do on top of that Leon what are
you doing my man side Thursday still
think he's server they've tossed some of
those good luck tracks back and no one's
watching the hash that's exactly what
punishing them he's gonna pick up two
he's going for gray and he gets a
joystick the first round 14 Empire even
though we had a limited OT on that
number one it wasn't the fastest there
you go joist oh okay how does he do it
cancer or Kenny and Goga fall this is a
huge breath of fresh air for Empire
additionally one of the first kills for
Team Empire came onto the heart preacher
Bob on a four ticks down Bobby and
alright joystick that's two for him in
the round he only kills for his squad
he's doing great just pushing into site
hang you from the West balcony gets one
as well so the roamers not really being
effective and oh [ __ ] bro the perfect
angle hikky deny the peat fall plant and
he gets four but he finally is
eliminated by Kendrick Eddie and the
Russian from blue bar it gova gets one
for from behind is he's gonna get run
out on that slick from quarry still
makes my head spin
now while sick Hills are awesome to
watch nothing gets the crowd going like
those big brain 200 IQ plays that really
remind you why these guys are the pros
here are the best utility plays from the
Rallye major the things were TSM is
currently in the elite up against the
Russian machine it might have this first
hole what where was that nitro cell what
in the hell was that
that was okay alright why the vigil this
time around recognize how the team
empire is in quite a good job all yet
the night result place over on minibar
mmm they will in order to get it through
oh gonna get him fall of this ramp II
does the electro shuffle impact through
he's literally dealing with every single
possible throwing at him
Grampy is an absolute madman he's
shuffling everything and he gets the XK
rolls
oh my god rappy you absolute monster
with utility and weapons he's got it all
Canadians
blow himself up what is happening wut is
this gaem ouncers roaming present
specifically from canadian here whose
beautiful plan that's exactly what we
needed to see from him well they are
getting in getting that patrol watch
soon or at least in the bottom half of
that rise doing that so the oh nice job
good teamwork there from riot or hicks
with the grenade and then rise finishing
off the drop on to thinking aides lista
kind of walked in here at this point
unfortunately and they gonna go in his
direction that will kill him sentence
i'm slamming into the wall involved as
well with those three on the board there
goes one detonating it's not gonna land
on to anyone but there's the third all
night rose all day it's fireworks inside
a penthouse but a smoke will have to get
very close he turns his back to thermite
takes down obama light some up but his
position is given away and because of
[ __ ] doing all of this renovation work
there's gonna be lots of sidelines what
a beautiful shot o jacory put this one
away without risking overtime now teams
picked a overtime side so this you'll
know what you're getting Dan inside a
reception knows there's somebody in
coach Chuck he's just gonna go right in
doesn't even need a ATS he's taking
cameraman how and then he has control as
well of the rotate I'll stare quite
intent they have da bomb be back at a
3v3 and Astro its punished by choice to
their Stan as well three on the board
miss still out oh poor Yuna - absolutely
silence cameraman but there's the cab
and are we gonna say it yes cheer loud
interrogation for astral empire
oh my you just have to sit and wait with
Shepherd and car Zeca there okay okay
okay
top floor was tried twice and it was
successful the second time there from
again team empire are not afraid to try
and knock down this time it's gonna be a
nitrous on to the bed he's got to pick
it up once again it flies through that's
gonna be an easy kill
bye-bye car Zeca no more puck upstairs
is that it's gonna be so difficult for
them to try and tear apart easy to set
up because ultimately they can't really
know that much about and a nade going in
it is gonna finish off Penghu and take
him down with achieved striking the
final blow to finish things off to be
spotted and now I think that's Pangu
who's gonna try and take a swing at them
a nitrous all being frontier being
launched out by odo weg a shock wave of
done for really helped open things up a
little bit number who knows Canadia
absolute GameChanger
that is unfortunate pasha was gonna go
down as well just i mean look how far
back they are to that cipher can be able
to come back but he's gonna be spotted
from the bout camp completely under
watch oh there's a c4 fabien just
exploding underneath cypher that's gonna
give an extra layer to this hold for
penguin also waste of the EMPs here
comes the van and trick oh the lifeline
successful though it goes low enough
they can come underneath the bear cave
but still Penghu tricks the wall truly
impressive through a lifeline no less
they haven't looked at comfortable at
all on
lobbying is very aggressive here and
it's I don't want to question it because
there's obviously a strategy you're not
gonna have g2 doing this for no reason
but there's two people watching and it's
a waste Fabien is so easily dealt with
well guys that's about it those are our
favorite moments from the Raleigh major
be sure to LIKE the video subscribe to
our Channel and let us know in the
comments what moments really brought you
to your face
see you next thanks for watching if you
want more content like this hit the sub
button and ring that notification bell
for unique bite-sized videos you won't
find anywhere else
hit up our Instagram Twitter and
Facebook pages
[Music]